nowadays the majority of the european
population lives in cities
and urbanization is further on the
increase
the quality of life in cities is
hindered by the environmental challenges
linked to increasing urbanization
this is why the european commission has
launched the green city accord
air pollution is the main environmental
cause of premature death
and disease the eu's air quality
standards continue to be exceeded
in over 100 cities securing clean and
safe water for a growing urban
population
remains a challenge as cities become
denser
there is increasing pressure on urban
green spaces
each eu citizen throws out nearly half a
ton
of municipal waste every year
inefficient waste management
means that significant quantities of
resources are lost
hindering the transition to a more
circular economy
environmental noise is a growing problem
at least 20 percent of the eu's
population
live in areas where traffic noise levels
are harmful to their health
the green city accord is a movement of
european city leaders with a common
vision
of making their cities clean and healthy
by the year 2030.
joining the accord means a commitment to
significant improvements in five
environmental areas
air quality quality of water bodies and
water use efficiency
urban biodiversity and urban ecosystems
waste management and the circular
economy
and combating noise pollution
in turn cities signing up for the green
city accord will enjoy a number of
benefits
locally they will increase their
credibility in the eyes of their
communities
by becoming more transparent and more
accountable
they will form part of a growing network
of like-minded cities
and be invited to capacity building
activities at the european level their
environmental achievements will become
more visible
let's make our cities greener cleaner
and healthier together
join the green city accord